[Música]
no
buenas tardes y no veo absolutamente
nadie supongo que hay gente aquí
muchas gracias por darme vuestro tiempo
se agradece
si vamos a google y ponemos en el panel
de búsqueda
entre comillas para que esta frase
exacta salgan
lecciones de la cob y salen o salieron
hace 5 horas cuando lo miro a mi
ordenador
36 millones de resultados
si lo hacemos en inglés live songs round
coudet talent
1.460 millones de resultados
en artículos académicos
periódicos
en revistas científicas
médicos políticos todos
y lo interesante es que bueno los
elegidos todos no los olvido todos pero
leído muchos quizá ya demasiados y tengo
una buena idea de cuáles son las
corrientes generales y lo que es muy
notable es como hay aunque estamos
hablando de algo científico de que hay
tanta diversidad de opiniones incluso
curiosos de butters
entre cuáles son las lecciones de la
comida o sea el tema el fenómeno de
nuestros tiempos el fenómeno diría
peligroso en nuestros tiempos la
polarización se extiende incluso a la
ciencia se hablan por supuesto de los
confinamientos que sí o que no a
confinamiento su confinamiento para los
vulnerables y no para nosotros y sin
mascarillas o no dentro o fuera o una
mezcla del oso que o protocolos en los
hospitales y si volviese a ver otra
pandemia si deberíamos darle más
prioridad
a la gente que tiene por ejemplo
posibles diagnóstico de cáncer o
problemas del corazón y no ponemos como
en segunda clase qué es lo que ha
ocurrido durante la pandemia que nos
vela
los que tenían que pasaban a la sala vip
opinión sobre esto quiero decir es que
hay mucho debate sobre todo esto lo que
de lo mucho que he leído lo que más me
llama la atención es que la gran lección
de lakovic es la que menos se menciona y
si se menciona que menciona de paso y la
gran lección de lakovic tiene que ser lo
que para mí ha sido también la gran
lección de la vida que extraído de este
periodo tan extraño de pandemia que es
el factor del azar como factor
absolutamente determinante en nuestras
vidas en particular empecemos por el
caso de la cob y el primero cómo empezó
esto hay dos versiones no se sabe cuál
que se rompió un cristal un tubo de
cristal en un laboratorio y ya y salió y
se expandió por el mundo o que el virus
saltó de murcia logró un pangolín a un
ser humano después salió de buján ese
avión y se fue a los al país de italia y
bueno ya y se expandió por el mundo y
después está el tema pasar en el tema de
los contagios porque uno se contagiaron
a otros no yo tengo muchos amigos se
contagiaron que tienen el mismo estilo
de vida que yo pero yo no me contagié
porque algunos se contagian una señora
acción años se contagia y lo pasa como
si fuera un resfriado y porque un señor
de 50 que hace maratones que están
impecables condición física se muere
porque algunos tienen secuelas otros no
y no hay explicaciones hay atento
intento de explicaciones por al fin de
cuentas es una cuestión del azar
lo que esto me ha llevado es
entender según veo yo que el azar es el
factor determinante en nuestras vidas
podemos intentar hacer planes podemos
intentar trabajar duro para triunfar o
podemos no sé cuidarnos la salud para
vivir más tiempo pero al final hay
factores aquí que simplemente no
controlamos
lo interesante es que en todos estos
millones y millones y millones de
artículos sobre las decisiones de la cob
y lakovic
no se menciona el factor suerte porque
porque esta naturaleza humana no
enfrentarnos a esta realidad en todos
los terrenos de la vida
intentamos buscar explicaciones queremos
querer sentir que tenemos control no
queremos lanzarnos al vacío que
realmente es lo que hay en la vida o sea
por supuesto podemos hacer cosas que van
a mejorar nuestra suerte que van a
mejorar nuestras oportunidades pero
primero viene la oportunidad napoleón
dijo napoleón uno de sus dichos más
famosos es que él no quería en primer
lugar generales hábiles
él quería generales con suerte lo dijo
napoleón porque porque la suerte es lo
que viene viene la oportunidad la
ocasión la suerte que cae del cielo en
el medio de la batalla o antes de la
batalla
y después entra la habilidad pero
primero tiene que venir el factor azar
el factor suerte la ocasión que quién
sabe de dónde viene
lo que quiero hacer en esta charla es
primero convenceros de el enorme papel
que tiene enlazar la suerte en nuestras
vidas como individuos como familias como
naciones pero no sólo eso no me quiero
quedar ahí sino que quiero extraer mi
gran lección del cro vives que a base de
eso entender que internalizar absorber y
actuar en función de esa comprensión de
la centralidad del azar en nuestras
vidas que uno va a vivir una vida más
serena menos rabiosa menos indignada
menos rival y que lo que yo llamaría la
doctrina del azar
sirve como antídoto al fenómeno más
peligroso en estos tiempos la
polarización que hemos vivido una época
de postguerra en el mundo ahora hay
mucha ansiedad mucha incertidumbre
estamos en una fase pre guerra pues la
polarización es lo que conduce a eso
lo que quiero es traer una lección
positiva de algo que no queremos
enfrentar pero si lo hacemos y si
actuamos en función de ello creo que
viviremos vidas mejores como individuos
y como colectivos como humanidad
a ver primero intentar convencer os el
mero hecho de nacer ya es increíble
porque se tuvieron que juntar dos
personas en circunstancias casi seguro
azarosas y después juntarse amarse hacer
lo necesario para tener un hijo y
después está el tema de donde uno nace
en qué época algunas por ejemplo fue
haber nacido el mismo día que yo una
persona con exactamente los mismos
atributos genéticos que yo ni digamos a
nivel mental de actitud pero no como
nací yo en un país rico con una familia
con aspiraciones una familia clase media
que quería que ayudarme que tenía
posibilidades de crearme oportunidades y
pero si hubiera nacido esa persona con
estos atributos que tengo yo en gambia
en burkina faso en pakistán pues su vida
hubiera sido casi seguro muy diferente
está este factor de primero dos
extraordinarios de haber nacido y
segundo donde uno nace después entremos
en por ejemplo la política que leemos en
los periódicos yo escribo artículos
sobre esto
análisis políticos o la gente en la
radio hablando de sus analistas
políticos pero siempre hay el factor
otra vez como en la cob y del factor
suerte casi nunca aparece y siempre es
tan determinante por ejemplo hubo un
primer ministro inglés en los años 60
que me preguntó una vez un joven
periodista es lo más difícil ser primer
ministro y él contestó events 10 voy a
ver los acontecimientos queridos los
acontecimientos si hacemos un análisis y
si se hace en un perfil de por ejemplo
pedro sánchez hablará de su
perseverancia por ejemplo muchos
obstáculos superar sí pero hubo
segurísimo uno o dos o tres son muchos
factores de azar en su vida que lo
llevaron a dónde lo llevaron empezando
por haber nacido donde nació en el
fútbol que es la gran pasión de media
humanidad yo creo que la gran pasión de
más media humanidad porque es un deporte
en que el azar juega el papel más
importante donde está aquí la merced de
fuerzas que lo que no se entiende no se
controlan en después de un partido de
fútbol siempre la gente se pregunta fue
un resultado justo
y es que refleja la vida misma por ser
un deporte tan
susceptible a la suerte
y a la justicia en justicia por igual
medida sin ninguna lógica en particular
después está el tema de la salud que nos
dicen todo el tiempo que hay que comer
bien que no hay que comer está que
hombre lo otra que tomar vitaminas hay
que hacer ejercicio y tal y cual pero al
final la idea y de fondo es que vamos a
combatir la muerte que yo creo que es el
principal motivo por el cual no nos
queremos enfrentar al tema de la suerte
porque la última estocada de la suerte
es una palabra que rima con suerte que
es muerte y este es demasiado duro y no
queremos enfrentarlo hay alguien que si
entiende esto en el mundo científico
médico muy bien y no necesito la
pandemia para para aprender la lección
tuvo una entrevista en el financial
times de londres en febrero del año
pasado justo cuando la pandemia estaba
empezando con un virólogo llamado
biólogo belga llamado peter piot en esta
entrevista le preguntaron sobre todo el
tema del virus este es un gran experto
ha sido muchos libros fue él combatió y
venció al ébola por ejemplo
y dio explicaciones muy técnicas de cómo
funciona el virus cómo penetrar el
organismo y tal pero hay una frase
lapidaria que dejó en esta entrevista
dijo peter piot el gran dios virólogo
del mundo lo más importante en la vida
es la ausencia de la mala suerte
y es lo mismo que decir no tener mala
suerte es buena suerte a ver hace 103
años tuvimos otra y otros tuvieron otra
gran pandemia de la gripe española
llamada gripe española de spanish club
en la que murieron como por lo menos 8
veces más personas que los que han
muerto por lo menos hasta ahora de la
comida
y ahí hubo mala suerte no hubo ausencia
mala suerte porque nosotros sí tuvimos
ausencia mala suerte pese a todo en
nuestra pandemia que el impacto sobre
los niños y los jóvenes fue mínimo la
pandemia la gripe española de 1918
no hubieron niños y mayores por igual mi
padre voy a hablar de mi padre y del
milagro
casi inexplicable de mi nacimiento y de
nacer donde nací con la suerte que tuve
de nacer donde nací mi padre tenía tres
años cuando esa pandemia de hace 103
años la sobrevivió murieron muchos niños
en glasgow de escocia el tránsfer y
padre combatieron la segunda guerra
mundial
lo derribaron pero en la fuerza aérea en
los golfos y aparte combatido toda la
guerra del 39 45 97 misiones cuando la
media para morir un volador en la fuerza
aérea era 30 misiones mi padre
sobrevivió 97 dos veces derribar a un
sabio alguna vez en el mar otra vez en
la tierra
vivieron pero sobrevivió ocho años
después de la segunda guerra mundial
mi padre esto es duro hablar de esto mi
padre que subiera un barco un ferry de
clases causas una tormenta tremenda que
el barco naufragó se hundió tuvo 160
pasajeros a bordo sobrevivieron 30 uno
de ellos mi padre
una de las personas que murió fue la
primera esposa de mi padre y tal estaba
destrozado se tuvo que ir de glasgow y
se fue a londres ahí
aparece mi madre mi madre había
sobrevivido a la guerra civil española
pero de madre mi madre
que fue a londres porque porque tenía
una hermana mayor en londres y se había
casado con un inglés por el que tuvo dos
hijos rápidamente se conoció en la
guerra civil y se fueron después a
londres justo la segunda guerra mundial
el marido de mi tía alvia la hermana
mayor de mi madre también combatió en la
fuerza aérea se murió en el primer vuelo
que hizo y dejó la tierra con dos niños
pequeños así que mi hermana y mi perdón
mi madre fue a londres era extraño en
esos tiempos una chica joven española
porque estaba porque esta cosa terrible
y las alas de la suerte había ocurrido y
ahí conoció en un bar a mi padre mi
madre habla inglés mi padre no habla
español pero bueno sin saber qué pasó
obviamente mucha química
y aquí estoy yo
y
y después como digo tuve tuve la suerte
de estar de hacer en un país rico de una
familia que estaba bien económicamente
con aspiraciones y después bueno ahí yo
tuve un buen comienzo algo que no
controle para nada y después otras cosas
ocurrieron que
les propongo que cada uno de vosotros
haga el mismo ejercicio mirar para atrás
sea como vuestros padres se conocieron
qué increíble que un día no ser
luisito desde el bar con conchita en el
bar y aquí estamos
y
por ejemplo yo tenía 20 años si alguien
hace un perfil mío ahora dirá que soy un
chico que escribe bien que soy bastante
listo que soy perseverante que trabajo
muy duro por lo cual no es verdad pero
bueno esto se podría decir que que mis
virtudes me han llevado por este plan y
he tenido sido un periodista bastante
afortunado pero
cuando tenía 20 años en una familia rica
vecina mía amigos en inglaterra en las
afueras de londres
tenían una señora limpieza filipina que
un día se fue que no sé si la
despidieron o si se fue voluntariamente
nunca la vi nunca la conocí nunca supe
su nombre pero este el hecho de que esta
señora que fuera este trabajo fue
absolutamente determinante no voy a
entrar en por qué pero créanme que si no
hubiera sido por esto algo que no
controle en absoluto mi vida hubiera ido
por otro trayecto totalmente diferente
casi seguro que no hubiera sido
periodista y segurísimo que no estaría
diciendo insiste sí que no estaría aquí
con vosotros esta noche no me hubiera
casado con una persona con el que case
el café no hubiera tenido el hijo que
tuve y así todo y después otras cosas
que tuviera suerte entrar en la
universidad de oxford digo suerte porque
es muy random todo el
proceso para decidir quién entra aquí no
había mucha gente más que se presentó en
youtube suerte él sin duda tuve suerte y
no es una falsa modestia y después algo
por lo que se me conoce y que ha sido
muy importante en mi vida a nivel de
perfil y económicamente es que hice un
libro en el que se basó la película
invictus restraint world esta película
no se hubiera hecho si no hubiera por
que un día por una extraordinaria serie
de casualidades yo aparecí en un
pueblito que nunca había visto antes en
misisipí y hoy llegué ahí exactamente el
mismo día mismo momento que llegó morgan
freeman a este pueblito y es una serie
de casualidades increíbles que me llevó
a este pueblito justo en ese día y ahí
conocí a morgan freeman porque me
presentó alguien que también porque
sólida conocéis y le conté la idea de mi
libro y él dijo vamos a hacer la pelea y
un par de años después twitter hace una
peli free para interpreta a mandela y
matt damon también está la película esto
y el azar en esta cosa fue total y
absoluto vayamos más allá de vida
también y os recomiendo que cada uno de
vosotros haga el mismo ejercicio con
vuestras vidas
el trabajo sea amor sea lo que sea
como estas cosas factores la suerte que
uno no controla han sido determinantes
por más que uno tenga empeño y muchas
virtudes después ampliándolo al terreno
nacional
político por ejemplo
pertenecemos a determinadas tribus
políticas o banderas nacionales también
por una cuestión de azar no elegimos ser
indiferente otra pista estas
circunstancias nos llevan a eso porque
nuestras familias nuestros amigos el
lugar donde nacimos etcétera esto esto
es lo que determina estas cosas es
importante saberlo para después tener un
poco más red compasión hacia aquellos
que son nuestros
antagonistas o incluso enemigos veamos
también ampliando el todo el siglo 20
quien fue la figura determinante del
siglo 20 seguramente adolf hitler hitler
era un mediocre imbécil resentido
y lo que él hizo fue canalizar el
resentimiento de todo un país de todo un
pueblo
y
si él no hubiera tenido la suerte de
vender esos cuadros que quiso vender en
viena
aunque nadie se los compro años antes
si hubiera triunfado en eso ha ganado
dinero ciudad incluso si mejor todavía
si sus mecenas y su principal comprador
hubiera sido un señor judío
casi seguro que la segunda guerra
mundial no hubiera ocurrido e incluso
frank o quizá no hubiera ganado la
guerra civil española que hubieran
evitado cien millones de muertes una
segunda guerra mundial vamos adelante y
hitler del siglo 20 en mandela alguien
que yo conocí muy bien el internal hizo
en su tubo en sus huesos
este concepto del del azar él entendió
esto sin tener realmente casi que
pensarlo él se entrevistó en la cárcel
con el jefe del servicio de inteligencia
de la parte de su enemigo más total en
un contexto de polarización absoluta
blanco y negro y la parte de sudáfrica
se vio también con ministro de justicia
de la parte de él y después de un
general que estaba a punto de ir a la
guerra con 30.000 personas armadas una
guerra civil se sentó con los tres y en
los tres casos convenció a todos
literalmente que se desarmarán y no sólo
eso los cautivos y los enamoró sí lo sé
porque he hablado con estos tres señores
largo y tendido están todos enamorados
de mandela porque bueno por la famosa
palabra empatía pero esa empatía probé y
proviene de que mándela entiende
entendió que la suerte fue lo que llevó
a estos señores a su lugar en la vida y
la suerte a él que él nació negro ellos
blancos mandela entendió que si lo
hubiera sido ese general que crear la
guerra contra contra él yo lo hubiera
nacido en una granja en el norte de
sudáfrica
en determinado momento que casi seguro
había sido un racista y empezamos ahí y
podemos ya bajar la temperatura de la
elección para mí de lakovic es esto que
sí internalizamos absorbemos y actuamos
en función de estado lo que llamamos la
doctrina del azar bajaremos la
temperatura seremos más serenos tenemos
menos rabiosos tenemos más dispuestos
a entender más que a juzgar a entender
más que a juzgar y ante todo cuál es el
gran valor de el que toda la humanidad
independientemente de raza religión
ideología comparte y que le da quizá el
máximo valor la generosidad y se absorbe
si actúas en función de esta idea del
azar de la suerte serás más generoso con
los demás
y serás también más generoso contigo
mismo porque sabes que mañana algo nos
puede pasar mañana alguien algo nos
podemos morir podemos sufrir un cáncer
quién sabe qué
nos va a ser más generosos con nosotros
mismos vamos a abrir la vida más
intensamente estar más agradecidos
disfrutarla más estar menos amargados
con nosotros y con el prójimo yo esto lo
estoy probando es mi lección de la
experiencia de la comida
todavía no actúa totalmente en función
de esto estoy en ello creo que me va
bien me está bajando la temperatura
dándome más serenidad más compasión y lo
recomiendo pruébenlo
[Aplausos]